SAYING THEY WOULD BE ARRESTED IF
THEY DIDN'T LEAVE NOW.
>> Todd: LET'S BRING IN JOE.
THIS REUTERS, WASHINGTON POSTS,
OTHER NEWS OUTLET IS -- LEAKING
NAMES ON CANADIAN FREEDOM CONVOY
AND DON'TAR INFORMATION CONTAINS
PERSONAL INFORMATION, IT WOULD
NOT MAKE THAT AVAILABLE
PUBLICLY, BUT OFFER TO
JOURNALISTS AND RESEARCHERS.
HOW RIDICULOUS AND OFFENSIVE IS
ACTION BY SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS?
>> Joe: NORTH KOREA STATE MEDIA
SAYS THIS IS GOING TOO FAR FOR
US TO DOCKS PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO HELP THOSE OUT
PROTESTING.
I AM OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER
SUMMER OF 2020 WHEN THE FUTURE
VICE PRESIDENT IN KAMALA HARRIS
STARTED A BAIL FUND FOR THOSE IN
MINNEAPOLIS, WHO WERE RIOTING AT
THE TIME.
I DON'T REMEMBER ANYBODY BEING
DOCKED AS FAR OF WHO WAS
DONATING TO THAT CAUSE.
WHEN YOU CALL TRUCKERS WHITE
SUPREMACIST OR NAZI AND THE FACT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ON THE
SIDE OF THE CANADIAN GOVERNMENT
WHEN THE PROBLEM CLEARLY, THAT
DEBATE WE SAW IN PARLIAMENT,
THAT WAS FACTUAL ARGUMENT BEING
MADE.
YOU CAN AGREE OR DISAGREE WITH
IT AS FAR AS ONE MEMBER, PUT TO
RESORT TO, YOU ARE SIDE WITHING
NAZIS REMINDS ME OF IT IS
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WHO SAID IF YOU DON'T SUPPORT
VOTING RIGHTS, YOU ARE FOR
JEFFERSON DAVIS.
CASES OF COVID IN CANADA ARE
DOWN 90% WHEN COMPARED TO A
MONTH AGO.
DOWN TO 5000 CASES PER DAME IN
37 MILLION PEOPLE,
WHY IS A VACCINE MANDATE GIVEN
TRANSMISSION IS DROPPING FOR A
PROFESSION ISOLATED FOR THE
PUBLIC.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER AND NOTHING
TO DO WITH SCIENCE, THIS IS
POLITICAL SCIENCE.
>> Carley: TRUDEA IS CALLING
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT THE TRUCKERS,
PEEP WHOLE WAVE SWASTIKAS, HE
WAS MAKING THAT TO A LAWMAKER
WHO WAS JEWISH AND WHOSE FAMILY
SUFFERED DURING THE HOLOCAUST.
THINK BACK, WHEN IT COMES TO
REUTERS REPORTING, THINK ABOUT
THE HUNTER BIDEN SITUATION AND
TWITTER WENT TO GREAT LENGTHS TO
SENSOR THAT INFORMATION.
ARE YOU SEEING THE SAME
REPORTING?
>> BOY, IT IS DISTURBING
PATTERN, CARLEY, NO QUESTION.
HUNTER BIDEN, IT WASN'T JUST
THAT THE AMERICAN MEDIA IN
OCTOBER OF 2020, COUPLE WEEKS
BEFORE THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, THEY DIDN'T REPORT THE
CONTENTS OF HIS LAPTOP.
IF YOU SHARE, YOUR ACCOUNT GOT
LOCKED.  THAT HAPPENED TO
KAYLEIGH McENANY WHEN SHE WAS
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY.
NOT ABOUT BIAS OF OMISSION, THIS
IS CENSORSHIP.
I BROUGHT UP NEW YORK AND NOW
WE'RE SEEING IT AND SUPPOSED TO
BE DEMOCRACYS IN AMERICA AND
CANADA MORE SOCIALIST, I THINK
THERE WOULD BE FREE PRESS, WE
ARE GOING IN THAT SDPREKZ TOO
MANY ARE SILENT ABOUT WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE.
>> Todd: AND JOE, THIS ILHAN
OMAR TWEET CONDEMNING IS
ASTOUNDING.
YOU HAD TED CRUZ SAYING, LISTEN
TO ILHAN OMAR.
I FAIL TO SEE WHY ANY JOURNALIST
REPORTED ON SHOP OWNER MAKING
SUCH AN INSIGNIFICANT DONATION.
WHAT DOES THIS SAY ABOUT THE
STATE OF JOURNALISM RIGHT NOW?
>> Joe: WOW, WHEN YOU HAVE TED
CRUZ AND ILHAN OMAR, REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS COMING TOGETHER
AND SAYING THIS IS WRONG, BOY,
THE STATE OF JOURNALISM, TALK
ABOUT TRUST IN MEDIA BEING
ALL-TIME LOW, WE ARE WELL PAST
BIAS.
TAKING A SIDE AND TRYING TO
STEER AN OUTCOME AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO SAY, IT IS
CHILLING, NO OTHER WAY TO
DESCRIBE IT.
>> Todd: LEAVE WITH A JOKE,
SEINFELD FANS, CRAMER SAID HE
WOULD GO WATCH CANADIAN
PARLIAMENT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
HAPPY BELATED BIRTHDAY TO YOU,
MY FRIEND.
>> THANK YOU SO